à parler d'un autre truc maintenant on
va parler également de franck ribéry
franck ribéry qui était au coeur de
l'actualité
ce week-end vous a fait un petit
récapitulatif de ce qui s'est passé
c'est la sphère de l'entrecôte ndour et
ribéry est-il la tête de turc des médias
vous allez voir ça c'est ça tout le
monde en a parlé
regarde c'est une nouvelle polémique
autour de l'argent qui a éclaté il ya
quelques jours sur les réseaux sociaux
opposant la journaliste audrey pulvar à
franck ribéry alors que ce dernier
profiter des vacances pour passer du
temps en famille à dubaï
le joueur a décidé de se payer une côte
de boeuf un peu spéciale puisqu'elle est
entièrement recouverte d'or une petite
folie de luc surtout qu'elle était servi
par le célèbre chef solvay star des
réseaux sociaux sur internet de
nombreuses personnes ont déversé leur
haine reprochant footballeurs de manger
un plat à 1200 euros soit le prix 20
smic il polémique qui enfle très vite
relayé par audrey pulvar qui s'est
indigné d'un tel comportement dans un
tweet
monsieur franck ribéry si vous ne savez
pas quoi faire de votre argent il reste
plein de causes à financer soutenir dans
le monde entier un commentaire que le
footballeur n'a pas du tout apprécié et
il l'a fait savoir en répondant à la
journaliste avec un article concernant
des lunettes de vue qu'elle aurait payé
3000 euros dans le passé je m'adresse à
audrey pulvar au madame je fais ce que
je veux de mon argent avec une paire de
lunettes à 3000 euros aux écailles de
tortue
j'espère qu'elle vous permettent
d'entrevoir un meilleur avenir
professionnel que celui de la pseudo
journalistes que vous êtes mais franck
ribéry ne s'est pas arrêté là il a
également posté un message sans détour
adressé à tous les acteurs qui ont
insulté sa famille je ne vous dois rien
ma réussite c'est avant tout grâce à
dieu pour les autres vous n'étiez que
des cailloux dans mes chaussettes
un message qui a beaucoup fait réagir
notamment du côté du bayern munich son
propre club qui a décidé de le
sanctionner d'une lourde amende pour les
insultes qu'il a proférées alors selon
vous franck ribéry est-il la tête de
turc des médias
alors c'est vrai que le bayern munich
l'a sanctionné qu'est ce que vous en
pensez de cette histoire parce que vous
l'avez vu je faisais avec franck ribéry
c'est un pote vraiment je les aime
beaucoup
franck et je sais tout ce qui fait pour
les associations et gelé défendu sur
twitter voilà qu'est ce que vous en
pensez est ce que vous êtes choqués ou
pas choqué par cette affaire dit la
vérité oui bon ben ali ben non moi moi
je suis il fait ce qu'il veut à la
presse et pas très malin dans une époque
où on voit qu'il ya des gens qui disent
oui mais tire la langue
c'est pas très malin de deux postes de
poster sa maintenance et son argent il
fait ce qu'il veut et par ailleurs il me
semble qu'il fait énormément sur les
associations et qu'il ne le crie pas sur
tous les toits que servent en parallèle
après moi le côté donneur de leçons de
goût
devrait pas faire comme ça avec ton
argent tu devrais mieux faire comme si
chacun fait ce qu'il veut vraiment dire
est qu'il est toujours de bon ton de
taper sur franck ribéry
j'ai l'impression du coin jury de nice
n'a il continue de payer des anciennes
histoires je veux dire à un moment donné
faut lâcher il gagne 8 millions d'euros
par an il en fait ce qu'il veut et en
plus il en donne une grosse partie aux
associations il n'a pas ce juste au mais
si en plus on a des informations qui
étaient fausses jusqu'à 1200 euros c'est
pas vrai non 1200 donc ça fait
maintenant six nuls et 289 euros bon
c'est quand même énorme et bernard c'est
une somme et dans ses défis mais mais
mais mais franck ribéry should i il fait
énormément pour les associations puis
c'est seulement s'il tonne
il donne beaucoup oui j'entends
parfaitement ce que vous dites est comme
valérie frances carte mais néanmoins
quand vous êtes footballeur
professionnel à ce niveau là pour moi
vous avez un devoir d'exemplarité l'ont
tous sens et l'on rentre ou alors il
fait plus rien non je dis juste je sais
qui donne beaucoup et vous en êtes le
témoin mais mais néanmoins on ne peut
pas insulter comme il l'a fait sur sa
xsara club symboliquement et même
financièrement le met à l'amendé le club
a raison c'est un problème typiquement
français en france qu'on sait qu'on ne
peut jamais montrer comment on dépense
son argent c'est toujours mal vécue
alors évidemment que c'est mal à vous
par exemple ont cessé dans les divorces
voilà mais c'est un problème après
ribéry c'est vrai qu'il fait beaucoup de
choses pour plein de gens maintenant
avec l'image de la côte dorée allez
allez allez allez pas terrible mais
après tout est ce qui me rend fou c'est
qu'en france dès qu'on a réussi un neveu
dès qu'on a un peu d'oseille
si on fait une vidéo alors on voit ça
bah bah oui bah c'est pas possible c'est
un problème
jean-michel jure avoir l'avis de tous et
ça faisait si mal ce soir j'ai une
excuse moi cristiano ronaldo tu ne cries
dit pas quand on ne montre qu'il roule
en ferrari ou en aston martin fall qui
roulait en tongs ou pour se faire
plaisir
excuse moi et me donne l'argent
mais eksi n'est vous saurez ce que dit
la vérité mon ciné est ce que toi tu as
chaud qu'est ce que tu aurais poster ce
genre de vidéos j'aurais tout à poster
d'accord mais ça me choque pas en fait
il allie notes faire ce qu'il veut c'est
bien sûr sur son instagram je pense qu
il a posté il a dit que la manger ça on
a sorti un prix déjà qu'ils étaient faux
moi ce qui me dérange c'est que s'est
érodée par elsie avec une fausse info et
là ça devient dérangeant c'est sur 56
les gens sur son compte ils vont
l'insulté tant pis pour lui mais ce
n'est pas une envie avec la foi était
mauvaise faites attention les mecs il a
raison signer